Longevity is almost impossible in music.
You know, it's hard in comedy
but I think it's almost
impossible in music.
Especially popular music, so
that's gotta feel amazing.
It's been a long time.
Yeah.
I don't know what else to compare it to.
This is the only life I've
lived as far as I know,
so it seems pretty normal.
But, yeah, there's not
a lot of the same bands
that we started with are still going.
What do you think has helped?
Because the band dynamic
is so impossibly...
Um...
it can be so corrosive
and bands usually just end up splintering,
falling apart into a million pieces.
Yeah.
What is it you think has
helped you guys stick it out?
First of all, we really need each other
but we're way more successful together,
than any of us would be separately
Um-hum
and so we're kind of stuck.
We're stuck together and
then just getting older
and, um, getting married to ...
other people. Women,
not us. Not each other
(studio laughter)
So you didn't all marry each other?
Well, I'm sorry.
I read this article, my research
who's doing the fucking research here?!
(studio laughter continues)
Says here
"and then in 1998, the band
all married each other.
This unconventional right
was sanctioned by the..".
Okay. Well anyway
That: that would not have worked.
I want you to think about it.
What do you think it is about
you guys all getting married,
which some people might think
that would pull you apart,
actually helped, helped you sustain?
Because you learn how to communicate.
Yeah
With, you know, in, in
your, in your marriage
you have, you have to and like, likely, um
yeah
your partner can teach you
so much about communicating.
And then in, in my case, so
I've been in couples therapy
for many years and just
learning, learning how
to communicate and then
bring that back to the band.
And it now, like things
that caused so much problem
in when we're in our early
twenties in the band,
and in some cases caused ruptures and
like all that stuff
would've been avoidable
with better communication
that we have now.
That's, um, I have found
that as time has gone on,
I look at myself in my twenties
and thirties and I was so
driven
and so ambitious
and kind of, I don't wanna, I mean
puritanical about This
is comedy and sacred
and I must be this way and
it's the only way it can be.
And, and then I attributed
a lot of my mellowing to
I've become more sophisticated
and I've, you know,
I've become, um you know, my, my marriage
of 20 years has really
helped me and my children.
And I do, you know, I, I've come up with
with all these ways in
which I've become wiser.
And then my wife's mom, my mother-in-law
who's very smart and
a therapist, she said,
"Well, your testosterone level fell."
(studio laughter)
And I went, What?
And she went, "Testosterone
levels with men,
they drop and yours, has, you
know, fallen precipitously
which is why you're so feminine now
and easy to get along with."
(studio laughter)
And I, I was like, Oh, okay.
Interesting. Thanks a lot.
I was wearing a wonderful
dress at the time.
Beautiful.
But uh yeah, there is
something about, I, I, I love
um
we all kinda romanticize,
or it's easy to romanticize,
especially when you're younger,
that kind of Neil Young.
It's better to, you know,
burn out than fade away and
you know, die young and
leave a good looking corpse.
And as you get old you're like, fuck that.
I want to be here and keep changing
and evolving and I'm
fascinated by the whole thing.
And I'd like to keep creating
and see what I can do.
And if people prefer the
earlier stuff or they
don't like what I'm doing
now, I'm gonna keep trying.